Speaker 1: So there are a number of stories
related to 20, 20 voter fraud that we will
be covering tomorrow.
And I have one for today.
And the the story is still all about voter
fraud for the twenty twenty election.
You might be thinking, wow, David, it's almost
June.
They must be talking about voter fraud in
some local election.
That was last month.
No, they're still talking about recounts,
audits, voting machines about the November
twenty twenty election.
OK, Zachary Patrizio from Salon has a wild
Twitter thread which outlines how my pillow
CEO and Trump crony Mike Lyndell claims to
have physically obtained Dominion and Smartmatic
voting machines apparently used in the 2012
election.
He claims to commit fraud in that election
and is hiding the machines around the country
almost like some weird geocaches.
Check out this complete absurdity.
Zachary Patrizio writing, quote, My Pillow
CEO Mike Lyndell is now claiming he has not
only obtained both Dominion and Smartmatic
voting machines, but also has hidden the machines
in secret locations around the country.
OK, so that's already bonkers off the wall.
Stuff goes on to say, quote, According to
a Mike Lyndell assistant who just spoke with
Salon, the pillow maven is currently flying
somewhere now and is unable to comment on
the matter.
Then it gets even wilder saying that, quote,
According to public information, I can confirm
that Lyndell is now flying aboard his private
jet tail number and 497 CP, which took off
from New Bedford, Massachusetts, and appears
to be heading west at this time.
Unclear if he is traveling with a voting machine.
They actually have the receipts from the flights
finding out that, quote, Lyndell made a very
quick stop at Elmira Corning Airport in Horse
Heads New York and is now on his way back
to Bedford, New Bedford, Massachusetts.
Remains unclear if a machine is riding in
hiding in horse heads and why it was such
a fast trip.
This is almost like a bizarre, backwards scavenger
hunt of some kind.
How much of this new nonsense of lyndell flying
around claiming to have voting machines?
How much of this is going to come out in the
civil suit against Michael and by Dominion
voting systems?
By the way, if he did obtain voting machines,
who did he get them from?
If you get an extra firm, my pillow, pillow
and it's a bit too firm, maybe there's a voting
machine in there.
I received an email from a viewer saying,
David, don't you realize what's going on?
This is Mike Lyndell starting to lay the groundwork
for an insanity defense.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Lyndell is a narcissist like Trump.
They don't think they can get caught.
They don't believe they will get in trouble.
Could this be the explanation for the recent
UFO UAP stuff that's been much discussed?
Could it be Mike Lyndell launching voting
machines around the skies?
No, I don't believe so.
Will they ever be done and satisfied with
the twenty twenty election and the voting
machine stuff?
Probably not.
But this is the latest.
Michael Andell reportedly now has voting machines
in his possession.
Really wild times.
We live in
a really wild
and depressing.